das rennen um den corona impfstoff auf
den wir alle so sehr warten weltweit
denn auch weltweit gibt es eben corona
fälle rund 20 kronach 20 millionen
corona fälle sind aktuell bestätigt
davon gelten aber zwölf millionen schon
wieder als geheilt
das warten auf den impfstoff könnte im
herbst ein ende haben
der wettlauf um den ersten corona
impfstoff er ist voll im gang so sagte
der präsident des paul ehrlich instituts
professor paul thek zu bild das der
erste impfstoff ende des jahres
zugelassen werden könnte
die voraussetzung er muss alle der drei
vorgeschriebenen testphasen durchlaufen
haben in der befinden sich laut
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu aktuell
6 von 165 impfstoffen an denen weltweit
geforscht werde darunter auch ein
impfstoff der deutschen firma piontek
und von kaiser der in den usa bereits im
test phase 3 ist noch weiter vorne liegt
angeblich das us-unternehmen moderner
während in china gleich zwei kandidaten
die entscheidende test phase erreicht
haben sollen allerdings fehlt es bei
solchen angaben oft an transparenz so
sollen in china impfstoffe schon
menschen verabreicht worden sein bevor
es überhaupt genehmigungen dafür gab
sicher ist bei der suche nach dem ersten
corona impfstoff wird auch von der
politik mit harten bandagen gekämpft
keine regierung will zweite sein wenn es
darum geht die eigene bevölkerung
wirkungsvoll zu impfen
in russland hat wladimir putin sogar das
militär mit in die spur geschickt um
einen impfstoff zu entwickeln
donald trump hat seinerseits ein
programm namens operations of speed in
gang gesetzt zehn milliarden dollar
sollen dafür sorgen dass bis oktober ein
impfstoff vorliegt derweil hat
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen eine
impfstoff allianz mit frankreich italien
und den niederlanden geschmiedet zu
klein für kanzlerin angela merkel
sie unterstützt ein gemeinsames vorgehen
aller eu länder beide
impfstoff züge und über den aktuellen
stand der korona impfstoffentwicklung
möchte ich jetzt mit doktor siegfried
throm von verband der forschenden
arzneimittelhersteller sprechen guten
morgen dr throm und morgen ich grüße
sehen wie ist denn jetzt der aktuelle
forschungs forschungsstand der aktuelle
stand ist so im januar wurde das erbgut
dieses neuen news veröffentlicht und wir
haben noch nie in der geschichte der
medizin so viele projekte gesehen etwa
170 impfstoff entwicklungen die zur zeit
zu laufen und sex sind schon in der
letzten phase angekommen also wir sind
relativ zuversichtlich dass wir bis ende
diesen jahres oder anfang nächsten
jahres die ersten zulassungen für oder
impfstoffes sehen werden und welche
unternehmen haben da die nase aktuell
vorn in der letzten phase sind zurzeit
impfstoffe von drei chinesischen
unternehmen von einem britischen
unternehmen von einem deutschen
unternehmen
von daher ist deutschland hier ganz gut
mit dabei die impfstoffentwicklung
erfolg allerdings international von
daher die zuordnung zu einzelnen ländern
ist nicht so ganz richtig heißt das dann
dass das unternehmen die jetzt die nase
vorne haben dann auch letztendlich das
rennen machen werden
das ist noch völlig offen zunächst muss
man abwarten wie die ergebnisse aus der
letzten entscheidenden phase der phase 3
ausfallen da wird der impfstoff dann
wirklich einem härtetest unterzogen ist
in impfstoff studien mit 15 bis 30.000
teilnehmern im gange
und da muss sich zeigen ob er wirklich
wirksam ist ausreichend wirksam ist und
vor allem ob er sicher ist
sie haben es gerade schon angesprochen
ob er sicher ist halten sie denn
impfstoffe zum beispiel aus russland die
hier nicht zugelassen sind für sicher
jedes land hat ein eigenes
zulassungssystem wir haben ein sehr gut
organisiertes
zur leistungs- eine sehr gute sogar
schon agentur in amsterdam thema die von
den nationalen zulassungsbehörden mit
unterstützt werden wir haben ein sehr
renommiertes institut für impfstoffe
hier in deutschland das
paul-ehrlich-institut was auch die
inhaltliche bewertung dann von solchen
impfstoffen markt und da bin ich sehr
zuversichtlich dass in der eu und damit
auch in deutschland nur wirksame und
sichere impfstoffe letztendlich
zugelassen werden und man hört auch
immer wieder den begriff effektivität
was genau bedeutet dass in der letzten
phasen muss sich zeigen ob der impfstoff
wirklich schützt das heißt ob die gruppe
derjenigen die den impfstoff erhält
deutlich weniger infektionen mit corona
dann erleidet als die vergleichsgruppe
die den stoff nicht erhält